hello everyone welcome
uh my name is camille and i'm very happy
to be here with you
this is our general meetup and we are
hosting it together
with hamburg nlp welcome so before we
get started and just that you are aware
about it
this conversation this meetup is going
to be on the internet later on
on pi data's youtube channel so
just in case that you are not interested
to have
your voice your face or whatever on the
internet
make sure and be mindful to uh rename
yourself
or to uh to keep mute um or just to keep
your video off
we are always welcome to interact via
chat we are going to pick your
your questions over there so whatever
few most
comfortable for you
if you have any questions throughout the
presentations or if you have any
questions throughout the event
feel free to just raise your hand and
will you answer your question
so these are your hosts for tonight's
meetup my name is camila
i work as an i.t consultant i'm also
supporting moin word at their mentoring
program if you're more inter if you're
interested
about it i can give more information uh
we also have
christian with us hi everyone
jen luca hey
and kai hi
and this is my data homework by data is
a global community
for developers and users of open source
data tools
and if you are interested this talk is
also going to be available
in pi data's youtube channel you can
also follow our social medias
specifically for pi data homework we
have our twitter
and our linkedin page and also our group
on linkedin so feel free
to follow us join us we will be very
happy with it
this is pi data hamburg team so here we
have maria she's also with us today in
the meetup
and christian and then myself and we
also would like to talk a little bit
about uh participation so
if you are working on anything
interesting with open source data tools
speak about it share with the community
so we are always looking for
speakers feel free to reach out to us in
any of the social media channels
especially if you are from an
underrepresented group
uh or a first-time speaker at pi date
i'm also going to talk a little bit
about that later on
we're also looking for volunteers so
meet up planning
speaking outreach and support in the
future
we also would like to get back to
hosting meetups and on site
so we would also be looking for uh
sponsors
at the moment not but in the future
hopefully yes
i would like to hand over now to hamburg
any lep hamburg
yeah so um
it's it's just very similar in
in well with one distinction from
a pi data so we are also focu
a community focused on on uh open source
tools and
and data processing but with a little
bit more
focus on natural language processing we
are very
young meetup group so our first meetup
just
took place september last year i think
so we are happy to
have uh our friends from pi data
giving us the chance to to host this
meetup together and
get to know a lot more of you and and
spread the word that nlp is an
interesting topic
and we take the the
title community quite serious so we also
have a slack channel where we
like open discussions and providing the
platform
to exchange knowledge and
prop even projects or or anything
that's connected to nlp and
if you like also private things but
focused on mlp
and um yeah
probably gianluca will you take over to
to mention some
of our other ideas i mean yeah
definitely so
uh we're we're pretty passionate about
uh open source as kai mentioned so
we have i think quite a few bits of code
some colored notebooks available
for each of our talks and we
of course it's never proprietary data or
knowledge but we like sharing as much
of the ideas that we present
as we can and the usually our
our group of members sort of consists of
everyone from data scientists branching
out into nfp
to computational linguists or linguists
as we've seen here
tonight in this meetup as well so it's
really
open to anyone who's enthusiastic about
nlp
and we also like to focus on
applications on bringing nlp into
production
bringing machine learning models that
deal with text and language
into production so if you're looking to
learn more about that we hope to see you
at our next event
yeah but with that i think uh unless
kyle anything more to add
i'll hand it back to camilla no camilla
go on please
okay so just in case that um you would
like to already put it in your calendar
i mean always remembering this
is a german-based uh meet-up group so we
have the next date for pi data hamburg
24th of march
and for hamburg and lep on 23
of february and i would like also
now if my slide goes
sorry
i would like to ask for three minutes of
your attention please
three minutes and it will be very fast i
promise you
i would like to get this three minutes
to talk a little bit about
um diversity inclusion and equity and i
know when i say these three words
i can feel that some people already like
bracing themselves
they're a little bit worried so relax
it's a very
uh relaxed conversation about that i
think we are in the beginning of 2021
and there is a chance that we as a
community as people working tech that we
can do a little bit different
and better than the private previous
years so
i would like to talk specially uh
regarding how to make
tech more inclusive and especially
events because
i don't know about you but sometimes it
bothers me when i go
in events and i see things that are
really like
sometimes not representative and don't
take me wrong
it's different when i say it's like it's
a one-time thing or if it's like okay if
it's for the past three
four years not representative so it's
important to
keep that in mind so i would like to
talk now
uh for events organizers i would like to
give you some tips on how you can make
your events more
uh inclusive or how you can at least be
a little bit more aware about it
so first thing and that's not difficult
it's about
checking your lineup so if you're going
to host events like throughout the year
check how is your lineup looking like
and for example let's say um
you only have people that like dogs in
your uh
lineup i mean just imagine the people
that like cats or fish
or horses they feel excluded right so
what about if you think about that and
you try to also bring
people that like different animals to
your meetups
that's one thing uh you can also hang
out with people
uh and communities that are different
from you let's say you are
a passionate dog lover well you can also
hang out with the people that
maybe they like cats fish birds or
whatever so
when you hang out with people that are
different with you higher chance
that you are going to be able to have
speakers that
are or people that are also from
different communities
and if you are doing your uh meet up
ask for feedback from people for example
how do they feel like
would they like to see different uh
speakers or how they feel about the
diversity of the event ask them
sometimes you get the answer sometimes
not but again it's on the responsibility
of those organizing it
to make sure that it's diverse and
representative
and have the commitment let me tell you
sometimes it's not easy when you
really are committed to make like the
diversity equity and inclusion things
happen
but if you have the commitment
commitment and you try out
things will happen i would like to talk
now uh
to the event participant and how you can
also help because you know
it's sometimes very easy to blame the
institutions or
put the problem outside ourselves but
sometimes it's within ourselves which
actions we can take to
make the change or the event participant
and i already did it many times
if you go to an event and you are a dog
lover or if you are
a cat lover and you only see like for
example
bird lovers ask them hey maybe next time
you can also bring like a dog lover or a
cat lover
just ask people for different things and
see how they react
one question sometimes has the power to
change the completely thing you are
doing
again for the event participant same
thing
why you should go to events that are not
really like your thing
hang out with different people will help
you to overcome your own bias so
it's also very powerful thing so try to
do that
and last message to anyone listen to
this and maybe you are part of an
underrepresented group and let me tell
you that
um it's sometimes very difficult to
touch upon that but
also for the underrepresented uh people
hearing that
be powered remember that you also have
the power to do
change and in case you cannot do a talk
recommend someone
from your own group as well that can go
there and can help on the diversity and
representativity
and just to make sure we have now 338
days
to make different and i mean still 2021
we have plenty of opportunities so
remember about that it's on us to try to
make tech a little bit more
uh inclusive and diverse that was all
the three minutes of your attention
thank you so much
and i would like to hand over now to
christian
yes our first talk um let's
welcome give a warm welcome to pumantut
who's
joining us from across the atlantic from
new york
uh it's great to have you here uh the
stage is yours
yeah uh thank you thank you for inviting
me to give the talk
so can i share my screen
yes you should be able to share
okay can you see it
just fine okay uh
yeah uh so uh hi everyone it's a
pleasure to meet you
or uh online and uh
my my name is pooh and i'm a phd student
at new york university
uh working on nlp and uh
today i'm going to talk about transfer
learning nlp tools and tips
so uh if you have like uh questions
during the talk uh feel free to admit
yourself and interrupt me uh i might not
see the chat
so yeah uh all right uh
let's begin the talk so in this talk i'm
going to
uh briefly cover what transfer landing
it
is and how it is used in our nlp and i'm
going to give you some tips on how to
maximize the chance of success in
transfer landing
projects and then i'm going to share a
couple open source chosen library using
nlp
these days and i also would like to like
give a shout out to my friends
jason and yada for helping me with the
slides and giving me ticks
so before we talk about transfer
learning let's talk about
supervised learning first so in
supervised learning we have a label task
data for a task
and then we train a model using this
label data
and then we only test this model on this
particular test so the task can be
intense or nlp the task can be something
like a sentiment analysis or question
answering and so on machine translation
etc
so we know that in deep learning uh
supervised learning tasks uh we actually
need a large amount of level data to
train the model
and to perform to make it perform well
but uh we might not always have uh
this large amount of labor data because
the data can be limited for
for example for low resource languages
or for very specialized domains
such as a medical domain or even for
like
english everyday language tasks we might
not have
enough data for uh tasks like symmetric
parsing or
uh dependency person because we need uh
export language annotation for those
kind of tasks so
data can be limited so what can we do
when we don't have enough data
so we can use transfer lending to get
like some sort of our performance
improvement
on uh those kind of tasks so
what is transfer learning transfer
learning is a way to share knowledge
across languages
or domain or related tasks and since we
are sharing the knowledge from other
tasks less training data is required
and since we are not training the model
from scratch
it saves time and computational
resources so it is likely
beneficial to use transfer landing
also transport learning has led to
important improvements in nlp these days
and it is really hot and popular in nlp
right now so uh why use transpoline nlp
so
language share a common linguistic
spreader
and grammatical information and so on
so it is like beneficial to use nlp uh
transparently in nlp
so for example this is the screenshot of
uh super glue benchmark which is
uh for evaluating the general linguistic
understanding ability
of uh neural network models and you can
see that uh
this benchmark is actually dominated by
um
transparent models and methods for
example like we have like broad and
all the variants of like transparent
methods and you can also see that um
there are two models currently
which has already stopped as the human
uh
baseline in this benchmark so yeah
these models are really performing very
well
in nlp so uh
there are many uh different transfer
learning methods
but uh in this talk i'm only going to
focus on sequential transfer landing
methods and
this method is also currently uh widely
used in nlp these days
so what is sequential transfer learning
in especially in
nlp context so as the name suggests
we are going to train the model in a
sequential way
so and do the transfer in a sequential
way for example we train a model on a
task
and then we use this free training model
to train uh
another task so we are going to transfer
the knowledge from the previous task
to train on that uh to get better
performance on the target task
so uh first let's talk about the
pre-training
so usually in free training we train a
model on data rich
source terms technically it can be any
source tests for example
on their models they use machine
translation as the source test
and there are models they use a natural
language improvements as the source test
but uh in recent days many
high-performance
uh high-performing models mainly use
language modelling as the
source objective so what is language
modeling
language modelling is the test of
bridges in the probability of a sentence
or a sequence of words for example are
given the token or
words h1 to hd we are going to train the
model to print in the
next word xt plus one so p of ac plus
one given h1 to ac
is a language modeling adjective so what
how can we use this so we can use
this kind of a probability information
to determine uh
whether the probability of apple given
ia is greater than verbiage of water
given i8
and so on so this this is like one of
the things we can do with language
modeling
information and the good thing about
language merlin
is that uh since we are predicting the
probability of the words or sentences in
the corpus we don't really need a label
data
and like a machine translation which
need uh parallel
data or natural language inference which
need the classification label data to
train
so it is really useful since we don't
need the label data we can just train
it uh on any test compass
so this is the reason it is widely used
and uh like i said many recent high
performance
models mainly use variants of language
modeling
in their pre-training objective for
example bird models from google
use a mass language modeling objective
and next standard traditional
objective so these are like a few
different variants of language modeling
so the first one
is for example uh just normal previous
language modeling
where they give you a part of the
sentence as input
and then ask the model to predict the
rest of the sentence so for
most language modeling we randomly mask
out some words in the
sentence and then ask the model to
either breed the
entire original sentence or only printed
the mask tokens in the sentence
and so on like shuffling where we give
you uh the model a shuffle sentence and
then uh ask the more to
uh recover the original sentence so
they're like different variants of a
language modeling
objective so
uh now we know how to do the base
training step
in the sequential transfer learning the
next step is uh to fine-tune this
free training model on the uh tiger task
that we want to
use so uh
so how do we do the fine tuning so we
in fine tuning stage we use the free
trade model reframe order can be
something like what embedding
so we're going to build a used board
embedding in a model and then um
use use it to find one on the target
test
or if we in the context of our language
models
we need to add a top specific
layer on top of the language model and
then train that
uh create the entire model on the task
so for example uh if we want to
do question answering we need to add a
layer or a few layers for
question answering on top of the
pre-trained language model and then
train the entire model on the question
answering test
so uh there are a few things we need to
consider
uh when we do that so first we need to
consider
which parameters we want to fine tune so
do we want to fine-tune the entire
language model
or do we only want to do fine-tune some
layers because um
the research has suggested that uh maybe
the lower layers are
better for syntax and the upper layers
are better for uh general information or
symmetric information
so what kind of information do we want
to fine-tune or
do we want to find your uh do something
good and freezing
which is like um the initial stage of
the training
only uh fine tune the last layer and
freeze the other layer
and then as the training continue
gradually and freeze the lower layer one
by one
and so on so this seems to improve the
stability of the training
uh so um do we want to do that
and also it has been shown that um
the landing rate and uh train the number
of training it bought actually matter in
language modelling
so we need to carefully consider and
choose those height parameters
so these are a few considerations that
we need to do during the fine tuning
so uh now we know how to kind of do
sequential transfer landing in uh nlp
can we get a little bit more performance
in an easy way
so yes we can so this is for
intermediate training or like a
supplementary training
called still so what they do is uh
instead of just directly fine tuning the
retraining model on the target task we
fine-tune it on the intermediate task
first
to do something like domain
interpretation or uh
to get like more knowledge on some sort
of tasks
uh so for example if we want to
find you on the free training language
model on uh
on a stack overflow question answering
data set maybe we can actually do
language modeling on the
computer science test the uh data first
to do the uh to adapt the language model
to computer science data
and then fine tune it on the stack
overflow data so this gave like some
sort of our domain interpretation uh
style improvement and uh gains in the
performance
so and also if we wanted to do like some
general question answering
maybe we can fine tune it on a related
task that is uh
similar to question answering such as
commands and reasoning and then finding
it on the question answering
so this actually gives a sensor
performance gain then
just directly find you on the question
answering data set
so this is for intermediate training
so also we
we can do something like zero shot
cross-lingual transfer
during the um sequence of transfer
lending
for example if we have a multilingual
model for example multilingual part or
hlmr
we can fine-tune this multilingual model
on an english task
so for example if we want to do
sentiment analysis we can find you this
multilingual model
on the english sentiment classification
and we can directly evaluate this uh
fine-tune more
on other languages for example we can
just use directly use this to
evaluate their performance on german
sentiment classification data
so this seems to do pretty well but uh
not the state of the art or no not very
like uh well yet
so people are still doing research on
how to do this better and we
also found in our paper that
using english intermediate has actually
uh performed
i gave performance gains in the
cross-lingual target tasks so for
example if we want to do
a german sentiment classification we can
actually find in the
multilingual model on an english
intermediate task for example
english natural language inference
intermediate trans and then we fine-tune
this model
on the uh english target test so for
example english sentiment classification
test
and then we evaluate on the german
sentiment classification test
so this actually gave a little bit of
performance gain
than the previous zero shot model
so another thing i would like to talk
about is a multitask lightning
so in multitask learning we train uh two
or more tasks
at the same time using a share encoder
so we would have like a pre-trained
language model as the share encoder and
then we
attached like a few different uh test
heads
to the uh pre-trained model and then we
train all those thoughts
at the same time together so there are a
few considerations we need to do
so first is by we need to consider which
kind of
uh parameters to share across the task
so because we might not need to share
all layers by
uh for a different task and then
some of the tasks in the uh
in the multitask learning
might have like a lot of training data
and but some of the tasks might only
have like very small amount of data
so if we just train then equally uh the
task with
a large amount of training data is going
to overwhelm the
task with a small amount of trained data
so how do we balance the task with uh
different sizes so we need to consider
this
i like how to do this in the multi-task
training
so uh next i'm going to
share a few useful tips on uh transfer
learning in nlp
so the first one is uh you might be
wondering
like how do we pick the task for
transfer and multitask landing
because uh if we bit the round task
the negative transfer can happen so what
is the
transfer negative transfer is uh when we
do the transfer landing
instead of getting performance
improvement the performance of the model
actually goes down
so this is a bad case right so we need
to be very careful about uh
how to pick the task so typically people
take the task based on a similarity of
the domain
so for example if we are going if our
target tax is in medical domain
maybe we want to uh take the uh medical
test corpus for intermediate training
or if people also pick the task in
terms of a task type for example if we
want to do question answering maybe we
want to pick a similar task
uh as the intermediate test or
people also use book blurry overlap to
pick the task
so maybe like we need to figure out like
how how many
words are overlapping between the uh
between the souls and the target tasks
and then pick that task as the source
test and
they're like some recent method called
task embedding which is
actually landing the embedding for each
task and then uh
choose the source task based on the same
based on the embedding similarity
between the
source tasks and the target tasks so uh
this is still kind of an open-ended
research question so people are still
trying to figure out way
the best way to choose like the source
task
for the transfer learning or the best
combination tasks for the materials
learning
and we are also still trying to work on
this um
question in our lab
so uh the next uh tip
is my uh language model by joining can
be very sensitive to
optimization parameters as i kind of
mentioned in the considerations
so it is actually very sensitive to
landing rate and the number of ebooks
so the recommendation is
to train longer especially for a very
small data set training longer
seems to uh give the stability to the
uh performance of the language model and
use a smaller than a very small linear
rate if you can
so uh this is why uh these two papers
analyze this and then recommended these
two facts
and another thing another tip is to be
mindful about uh catastrophic forgetting
so catastrophic forgetting is a
forgetting of the previous
previously land information when you're
trying to land new information
so for example let's say we have a
multilingual model and we train the
multilingual model on english test
to do the zeroshot transfer so when we
do this english training the model might
forget
uh previously learnt information about
other languages
so this can happen and we need to
uh prevent like this by adding some
regularization methods to
uh minimize the catastrophic forgetting
so um in multitask learning like i said
uh
if we can have like tasks with different
sizes
in our multistar microtest landing
training
so how do we balance those tasks so
people usually balance the tasks based
on data set size
so like maybe trying and some other
people also use temperature based
sampling
so what they do is they first balance
the task based on the dataset sign
so but uh try to use some kind of
temperature to assemble the
tasks with a smaller data and downsample
the task with a
very large amount of data so that all
the data set gets
the attention that they need and then uh
there are
also research going on to automatically
land the task ratio
or the task weight during the
multi-translating using metal lining
so this is also like an additive area of
research so
people usually use my data satisfies and
try to find you in the
trying to find the temperature based on
hyperbromide genetic methods
but uh there's still a lot of research
going on about how to do
like this automatically
another thing and i think this is very
important is to be mindful about social
biases
in a retrained language model and the
data set that you are using especially
if you like want to use that
in production so for example this is the
uh visualization of the gender bias
by robot the large model which is a very
popular model from facebook ai research
and fine tune on the squad question
answering data set which is also a
popular question answering data set so
you can see that uh the more
actually associate female with a worse
light babysitter
cashier clerk cook and dancer
why it associates meal with banker
bodyguard
uh captain butcher and so on
so this kind of social bias is about
gender
or religion or nationality
and so on exists in the language model
so please be very mindful about those
biases when you especially if you want
to use that in
production yeah
so another tip uh we would like to share
this is mainly for implementation
so uh a lot of things to stay a lot of
things that stay very hand wavy and you
might need to run a lot of
experiments with uh different data sets
or different uh combinational tiles and
hyperbarometer before finding one
that works for your task so uh
it is very important to uh use a modular
plug-and-play uh
code for different components of the
transfer lining
so for example like maybe uh add some
components for our testing and
sunglass training and so on because uh
so that if we want to change one part we
can change it without affecting the
other parts
of the code and we need to save like
more confidence and check
twice a regular interval so that we if
like something happened we don't have to
start from the scratch again we can just
start from like one of the checkpoints
and uh so and we can uh produce
parameter
uh parameter and performance logs at
every step so that uh
it would be easy to debug and it will be
easy to check like which
edit which stage the performance is
going around so that we can just restart
from the stage
and start like doing for everything from
scratch again
which can be very expensive and we
should automate online
the experiments uh as much as we can
so actually we i i'm going to introduce
a library called giant
which actually handle all these steps
later
so yeah this is like kind of a promotion
to our model so
first uh now i'm going to introduce some
uh
open source tools so i think
everyone who works in uh nlp kind of
know what uh hacking faces
so uh this is a very good library and so
the first one is how
do we find the data set easily so hug
and face has like a lot of data set
and those data sets are in like many
different languages
for example you can just go to uh hug
and face dot co data sets
and then you can like search for the
kind of data that you want and you can
also filter by language
or the size of the data set and it is
very useful so
after finding the data set for example
this is like a chronic
identification data set you can just
directly
use like front data set import load data
set and then directly use accounting
identification data set
so you don't have to i do um
so this is going to download the data
automatically for you and load it in the
data set of variable for you so you
don't have to handle like data loading
steps and
so on in your code and it's very useful
and they have like
data set many different data set in many
different languages
so this is very useful the next step
is uh where do we find the brake train
model so
hug and face also holds uh very popular
free training models
from a research lab and also they also
accept like uh
the submission from uh open source
developers so we can also submit our own
model to hug and face data set so
and we can also search for models so
for example if we want to search for
send a model
that is already trained on sediment we
can actually just uh
go and search in sediment and it will
give you a list of uh
models that are actually already fine
tuned on sediment we can even say
there's like a german sediment right
so yeah
this is really useful and next
uh how do we set up our transfer
learning experiments
so we can actually use a hugging phase
to do
uh transfer learning experiments also
but we most of the codes
need to be written on our own uh
so we all in our lab we built a library
called giant
which is a pie dash library for natural
language understanding
and it focuses on multitask learning and
transfer learning research
uh it is mainly focusing on research so
it contains
a lot of like popular data sets and
tasks for uh
task people in nlp research usually use
but you can also add your own
uh tasks and your own data
uh if you want to use it in a production
so this library is very simple flexible
and it has like very flexible training
pipeline
and it is built on the huge face
transformers and data sets so
it you can seamlessly um
use huge face models and data set in our
giant library and this library is
designed to be much
modular so that you can just like change
any part
in the um in the library on your own if
you need to modify
and you can just do plug and play any
part of the world floor
and it is also very easy to add your own
uh tasks and data set
and we also have like we also we also
keep expect
expanding our library and like the
tossing
in our library so uh if you're
interested you can uh
go and check out gian.m4 so i am going
to
talk a little bit more about a giant
so giant contains three components
uh it has like task model and runner so
first uh
task so the task intensity test giant
support
50 plus tasks out of the box most of
them are very popular
on nlp tests using uh research
and uh we also have some kind of like
nlp
programming test which is like uh bro
the transfer
uh those are the tasks for like probing
the model
uh whether the model know some kind of
linguistic information or not for
example if uh we have like uh
any of robin toss this is going to like
broke the model whether the model know
and your information may enter the
information or not
and like i said it's easy to add a new
task
if you want to use it for your own
custom data set
and we if you are a researcher who wants
to
use it uh to submit
uh your date your data your model's
performance to
like natural language understanding
evaluation of benchmarks like blue
which is the general language uh
understanding evolution
benchmark and super glue which is like a
harder version of glue
with a low resource data set or a stream
which is a multi or cross-lingual uh gen
language evaluation dataset so if you
want to do like submissions to those
kind of uh
popular benchmark you can directly do
that in uh using giant
so this is like convenient if you are a
researcher
not so much with your uh
a developer so we also have a task
downloader
so this is my um
a downloader that is going to download
the tasks or data
from the hacking face and then get you
can get started right away
if you want to like use hug and face
data set
and we also include a necessary
pre-processing
code for the necessary reprocessing
steps so
uh because the pre-processing such as
tokenization
should be done for like differently for
different models for example bot has
its own part organizer robotic model has
uh its own robotic tokenizer
so we handle all those things in our
library so it is
really useful for a custom data set you
just need to choose like
uh how to get your data and then uh
the rest is going to be handled by giant
um so the second stage in giant is all
models so a giant model consists of a
text encoder which is uh
the bot model or robotic model or the
pre-trained language model and we have
like uh one or more
test specified data set heads so like i
kind of mentioned before
uh if if we want to use a
bridge train language model we need to
build our own uh test specific heads
so we giant already have like a lot of
our heads
implemented in our library
so we can just choose like any head to
go together with the encoder
so these are the kind of uh the
supported uh
test head in our uh library so currently
we can do classification regression
multiple choice taking a multi-level
multi-level span comparison question
answering mass language modeling
and spam prediction tasks such as my uh
squad question answering and so on
uh we cannot currently do generation yet
so you know you cannot use giant for uh
generating the data or machine
translation but uh we might add this
on the board later on and we also
support
most of the popular free training
language models such as uh bot
robot and multilingual moral asl are
albert
and bart and so on and we this is also
like expanding
uh and the last
step is called runner surrender is uh
the
the part where we are going to train the
model so the training loop
and um how to balance the data and so on
and like logging off the
train step and saving the models and so
on are handled by
so rena handle a training and evaluation
control flow
and it has a native support for
multitask training so
uh it also let you like choose different
types of sampling
for multi-task training and the score
aggregation strategies for how to
maximize the performance
for different tasks so in moderators
training you might want to
maximize the performance for all the
tasks or maybe you might want to
maximize the performance for one
particular
task and you might not really care about
the performance of other tasks in
training
so we let you do that by by letting you
choose the score aggregation
uh score aggregation strategies
and we also support things like early
stopping of the training
and saving and loading of our checkpoint
and things like gradient accumulation
and multi-gpu parallel training and so
on
so this is the pipeline for giant so
first we
need to download the data usually this
is like
um uh then using the hug and face
library
and we we have the code that handles
that
and then uh we need to download the
model that we want to use
then after that we need to tokenize and
cache the data
using the uh tokenizer from the model
and then we have to write a config for
training the model such as like how many
uh
training steps do we want to use how
what is the best size
if we are using multitask training how
do we want to assemble the task
and uh yeah other specific training
related details
should be written in the random
confidence and then we can just like
run the experiments and it will handle
the training
and the rest for you so it has two
different api
the simple api which does all the
every stage in the pipeline in a single
call
so it download the model pre-process and
do the training on its own
by just like one line and this is like
the starting point for everyone so we
can just rent this comment for example
uh we can give the training a name
simple
and then we can specify the experiment
directory
and then we can specify the specifying
the data directory
and then we can specify the model that
we want to use
so in this case it's part based and we
can specify the task
so mrbc is kind of like a reading
comprehension task
and rte is a natural language inference
classification test
so this is going to be a multi-task
training since we specify our two tasks
and we can specify things like batch
size and training ebook and also
we can specify learning rate and so on
if we don't specify it
well there are some default learning
rate already set for uh
doing that in the library
so the second k this is the simple that
was the symbol
api the second case is the main api
so in may api we have command for each
step in the pipeline so you can just
like modify any step
on your own and then uh so it's good for
customizability so for example
like for download data it will have like
the code for downloading the data
and if you want to use your own data you
can just modify this step
and um yeah and any point
in the pipeline you can just directly go
and modify this step
like without affecting the other parts
of the
uh pipeline so
and the question is like how do
we if if you want to add on your own
tasks how do we do that
so we also have like very extensive uh
documentation on our
github so you can like uh read this
and then uh yeah try to
add the your own thoughts and models and
you can also contact us
or submit an issue on our github if you
need help doing that
so uh is there like any question
so far until now
if you have a question for who you can
unmute yourself and ask directly
or also post the question on the chat
and we're going to read it
okay my question i had one question
yeah um if you mentioned
in the beginning that this language
model introduced this
gender bias so the gender buys basically
come from your training data
um and as
long as you're training with this data
you you cannot do anything
with it so how would you mitigate it
uh yeah so i all these free trained
language models
are usually trained on uh publicly
available data sets such as wikipedia or
reddit data which is like really bad in
terms of
social bias so there are papers
which propose like methods for uh
like reducing the bias um
in uh wires of those models so like we
can use like
d biasing methods and so on but uh i
think still
uh the bias is going to exist so
uh especially if your data
set has like uh is biased for example if
you're doing like resume uh
scanning uh resume scanning model so
uh the dataset that you train might
already have like some gender bias
so you have to like uh
maybe uh build the data or like filter
the data on your own
to be like to balance the gender uh
ratios in the data set itself and then
also like
use some kind of regularization methods
to uh like
mitigate the bias of the model itself
there is another question from the chat
have you tried genetic
programming for nlp and i would add um
is genetic programming
relevant in the nlp field uh
i have not tried it and uh
yeah i don't really know a lot about
that topic to comment
sorry about that yeah
but uh if the if there are people who
know like favorite timing
any more questions there's a follow-up
question
about gender bias coming
one question that i was curious about
this handling this general bias issue is
that
do we do you know about the existence of
data sets
which identify whether some sentences
are
biased gender biased or not in that case
maybe we could
run it run
a model retrain a model on that data set
and then apply it to identifying the
bias sentences in the current data set
um i i don't think i have seen the
cinema data set that actually
uh find the bias in the data set itself
i have mostly only seen the data set
that specify
the uh biases in the model that is
already trained
so but you can use those data sets for
example you can train a model on uh
your data set and then you can use that
uh model
and then uh make the model to predict
uh uh they did the uh
gender bind sentences and then um maybe
the
uh the gender bias data set would tell
you that your model is actually biased
so maybe that that's the only way i
currently know right now
and i don't think they're like uh
methods that directly specify the
a sentence that is biased
because it's really hard to tell
so for example this uh ancover dataset
is a way to identify the bias in the
sorry for going back
so this is the the more the data set
that i
show in the demo so it contains like
sentences like this
for example uh
we have like uh an example paragraph
about gender
so the person over the sun is angular
and citrine by the sec is
uh sitting by the site is battery so who
was an entrepreneur
so the model should be like uh
a bias model is going to answer that
battery is a
an entrepreneur so there is like no
information
about entrepreneur in the sentence at
all
but unbiased model should say like 50 50
probability that
both angela and betray can be
entrepreneurial so
the bias model stays by triggers
entrepreneur and so on
and they have like racial bias for
example asian woman was taking classes
and with a caucasian woman who is a bad
driver
and the bias more is going to answer the
asian woman is a
bad driver we can use this kind of data
set uh
to test whether a model is biased or not
okay so it is more difficult to identify
the intrinsic biases
thank you
chris is asking have you come across any
data sets that
labels imperative sentences sentences
that require a task
and this is required uh can you give me
an example
of that so
so like oh any data set that labels
imperative are
oh examples coming like please send me
the report
or can you take out the trash oh it's
clarifying
so it is like uh so for example for
those
sentences we need to identify the task
or the intention i think there are
some intern classification data set asis
yeah
so yeah i don't really know anything
uh right now or out of the top of my
head but they definitely exist
especially in the conversational moral
field i think
yeah sorry uh here's another question
from jacqueline if you have multilingual
pre-trained data
why would you train your data on an
english data set if you want to apply
your model to
german data wouldn't that rather cause
interference
yeah so if you uh already have
a geometry a large german training data
it is best to just directly train on
that german training data
i think the cost for spiritual uh
cross-lingual transfer learning is
mainly for low resource languages where
we don't have like enough data
for uh to train the model for example uh
my native language burmese don't have
don't really have any good data set
so and they are not publicly available
even if they have them
so we need to do this kind of uh cross
language manipulation
to like do well on some tasks
yeah but it is the best to just directly
you train on
the target language data if you have the
data
and also cross-language training or
cross-lingual intermediate training can
give you some performance gains
if uh the source language is very
similar to the target language
for example spanish and english are kind
of similar in terms of
some step worst vocabulary so it can
give you performance gain but
english might not be very useful for
like
uh languages in other language families
such as uh
two-fashion languages or promised
languages
um how much time do i left for a demo or
take your time for for the demo are
there any urgent questions
for poo before she shows us the demo
no so i think you're good to go with the
demo
okay so uh this is the link for the demo
i will also place it in the chat
or in case you want to
do it on your own
so this is just like showing how to
train a multitask model in giant using
uh some popular datasets such as rte
which is a classification
task for uh natural language uh
inference and stsp which is a stanford
sentiment analysis
data set and common sense qa a qa task
for uh
common sense reasoning so first
we need to clone the library and install
the requirements
so i already kind of rerun this uh
before coming here
and then uh the first stage in the
pipeline is to download the data set
so hug and face uh we are going to
download the data set from hugging face
and save it in our output path so
we specify the tasks that we want to
download rte stsb and commonsense
security
so if you have implemented your own task
in our uh
library you can also specify the name of
the task
your own task and then after that uh
we are going to import some libraries uh
and um yeah functions that we're going
to use
from giant and then we need to download
the models
so if you have your own model you can
use your own model otherwise uh
we are going to export the mortar from
hugging face so currently
this is using a robot a base model from
uh
hug and face and then we specify the
puff to save the model
so yeah and then the next step
in the pipeline is to do tokenization
and catching up the model so that we can
easily uh
use it during the training so we are
going to
identify the tokenizer that we want to
use which is the robot
based organizer since our model is robot
based and then we are going to identify
the
path for each data set so the configs
are going to be
they're automatically downloaded when we
install giant
and then we are going to tokenize each
task
so this is going to be handle the
tokenization is going to be handled by
giant also
and then we are going to
uh cache each data and then print out
the data
so this is like how the data look like
after converting the words into indices
and this is my
uh the original sentence in uh
uh that is already tokenized for example
like no weapons of
mass destruction and this we have this
kind of a weird g
symbol because the tokenizer is using a
bpd organization which add those kind of
uh tokens
in the during the tokenization stage
but we don't have to worry about that so
this is just like a printed outside kind
of data from different data sets so this
is live from rte
and uh sdsp and common sense qa
so after that we can start
writing the rand configuration so uh
we are going to use simple multi-task
configuration
configurator api so we specify the
um tasks that we want to use in the
training
and we want with the task that we want
to use in validation
so for example we might want to maximize
uh
the performance of all tasks so we
might want to use all the tasks in the
valid edition or maybe we might only
want to use like rte because we only
care about rte performance
so maybe we might want to only validate
based on rte performance and we can also
specify the training set
set training batch size and evaluation
batch size
and how many epoch do we want to train
and how many gpus we want to use
if you have more than one gpu you can
specify that and the
china is going to handle the parallel
training for you and doing the multitask
landing stage we can also
like specify how do we want to assemble
the data so proportional assembling is
going to sample the data
uh based on the data set slide
proportion
but there are other um assembling
methods such as temperature sampling
and other advanced assembly methods that
are in giant so you can
take a look at the library uh for more
information
so and we have like other test
configuration
that are like set by default
yeah and we are using a
aggregation method equal metric
regulator so we want to
focus on all the tasks equally and start
by just one task or send
tasks
and then we can just like use this rank
configuration that we
wrote just now and then uh use it to
like rent so we can specify the landing
rate that we want to use
how frequently do we want to do the uh
evaluation and do we want to train or do
do we want to validate do we want to do
only one of them and so on
and if we have like a sample trade model
do we want to override the refrain model
or do we want to just pick up from the
uh previously trade model and continue
training
that so we can specify all these uh
in our rank configuration and then we
can just
do like a ram loop and then run argument
and then this is going to start training
the model
and uh yeah so this is like
first it brings out all the moral
confidence so that uh we can remember
then
for debugging and uh
so this is just a logging and after that
it is going to
start training the model and evaluate
every step
and then at the end is going to produce
the
performance for each of the tasks
so uh this is really useful if you are
doing a
nlp research but also in production if
it is like easy to add your own tasks so
it could be useful like this
so any uh question regarding this
any urgent questions because we should
be going to a 10 minutes break but first
of all
thank you so much let's have a round of
applause thank you for the great talk
yeah thank you everyone for attending
and uh
discussion yeah thank you
and thank you also for inviting me
i don't see any urgent question
let's go to the 10 minutes break and
then meet again for the second talk of
the evening
anybody who doesn't need a break is
happy
[Music]
welcome to to network if if you
do like that
do you want to start with we
every one of us has one name then we are
equally uh
doing some introductions so because it's
so
few words okay so um
we'll have our second talk now which is
more about applying nlp in production
and our speakers today sebastian nisten
from
ginkgo analytics and adrian
baitou from hapag lloyd will be talking
about
nlp based customer service automation
at scale so i think i have already
dealt with most of the introduction now
and we can hand it off to our
speakers
thank you let me share the screen
good yes uh thank you and a
warm welcome to um to you
to the community and thank you very much
to having us
here really happy um
maybe not everybody will know what
haploid
actually does but if you look in the
background of this image
you see that we have a lot of containers
and we have quite a lot of big vessels
and we basically move cargo over the
ocean
door to door worldwide we are the fifth
biggest carrier in the world
and nowadays even the most
profitable one so
as you can imagine
there's quite a lot of communication
going on between
us and the customers legal entities
service providers
and also we provide a lot of digital
products
to to have optimized access to our
services
a lot of communication arrives us as
email
um so
2019 we started a couple of
proof of concepts in the area of nlp
and today we want to show you what we
achieved
and how we got there
my name is adrian baetu i'm since
eight years with harper gloyd i have
quite a rich
history in the area of system
engineering
and my love to ai actually started
during my studies when i had the chance
to play around with my first
back propagation algorithms so you can
imagine
how how good it feels nowadays because i
didn't lost my love
till now and now i'm i'm
allowed to build up the first ai team
at habergloid but let me introduce now
my uh my partner on this journey
sebastian nichten
yeah hey guys exciting to be here uh
welcome
and hello also from my side yeah my name
is i'm a senior data
data scientist working for gingko
analytics
we are a small consulting firm providing
data science as a service
to a lot of the big clients in germany
deutsche bahn
lufthansa merck and of course hubbard
lloyd
i will try to introduce myself really
quickly but i
think this might uh be very really
valuable
especially for the people here that are
just getting into the field of data
science
um so yeah i actually studied
process engineering i finished my master
in 2017.
i then decided to go with my passion
which
was more of a side project back then
which was machine learning and data
science i went to university of hamburg
for one year
took all the classes there that are
related to that topic
then i participated in a lot of
hackathons uh
in and kaggle challenges which i can
highly recommend in the beginning
especially
uh because there are really skilled data
scientists there
in these online communities and a lot of
code um
where you can learn really uh hands-on
um
how to solve tasks and then in 2019
i joined ginger analytics i worked with
a few clients and then
uh were started working also for
lloyd um actually i met adrian uh
over a meetup which is kind of nice and
now we are talking together
at one yes
so yeah meetups are also really good uh
platform especially when you're in
person of course
um yeah we prototyped six nip use cases
um and in two thousand
we actually deployed two of those which
are currently live and automating over
11 million requests every year thank you
for now and for now back to you adrian
thank you sebastian so quality is
actually a promise
that hapag law gives to our customers
we have recently deployed a dashboard
that is publicly available
so our customers can see how we
are striving to accomplish these
promises
and the solution that we are going to
present to you today
is one building block that allows us to
improve
and achieve this promises
i will give you a short introduction to
into the business case itself sebastian
will go deep dive with you into the
technical solution
and at the end we'll talk about some
success factors
that made this results possible
so what we are gonna talk about today
is is the bill of lading
probably not many people know what a
bill of lading is it is one of the most
important
documents in the shipping industry it's
a legal binding document
and it basically contains all
information required for transporting
the cargo so if you look to the left
down the story starts with a customer
sending us
instructions with when he wants his
cargo to be transported where it starts
where it should uh go to so destination
what will be in it how much who pays
what and
we are compiling this to a first draft
of this
bill of lading return it to the customer
the customer might have some change
wishes
um and eventually after some force and
back
we will end up with an approval from the
customer
so we can release the official bill of
lading
and then only then the shipment can
start
so can go on the vessel and go towards
its destination
behind the scenes we have to deal with
40 000 emails per day
they arrive as in parallel the customers
are sending them in parallel to us
in various formats and mostly in
unstructured
text like you see it below um
so we have a team in the middle who has
to read the mail understand
and see is it an initial shipping
instruction is it a draft correction
request
is it an approval so they tag it like
that
and send it to the right expert
to provide the answer we of course have
the support of our fright information
system
but still there are quite some more
uh types of maze that we have and
this process can take fit between ten to
two hours per mail yeah forty thousand
days per day
one ten minutes to two hours uh this is
not because
the people are so uh so slow or because
the males are so big
but it's just due to the volume yeah so
it piles up
and um that's why you end up um
taking a long time for one male and this
is exactly what we addressed
we introduced an ai that can read and
understand the male to the extent that
it
it can detect the the the type of the
male
initial shipping instruction drop
correction and seven more
so we reduce the time of this process to
three seconds because the ai can scale
if you do it right
so sebastian will tell us how to do that
right right
yes uh exactly so
first of all i would like to go into a
little bit of the requirements
to make ai work in production
so first of all we
i would recommend always to first have a
prototyping phase
so in that phase you actually get the
historical data
of your use case in this case in this
scenario the emails from hypagloid
together with the labels from a database
um that are currently filled by humans
and then you also of course need a
experienced data scientist
who then does all the data exploration
cleaning model design
design and training and
also a subject matter expert so in this
case um someone from hubbard lloyd who
actually
knows the process really well and can
you explain to you all of the classes
and the data that you get and then
on the deployments side so when when the
prototyping leads to good results is
successful then you go
and try to deploy your solution
um here you require a digitalized
process
um so that um you just can kind of plug
your ai module into an existing
um yeah a structure of of uh
um yeah of the it for example in this
case of hypergloid
and um and yes and what you also need is
a deployment environment so
something for example a cloud
provider like aws or google cloud they
provide you
a lot of managed service for models
services for model serving
they provide you with with
functionalities like scalability
availability they think about security
compliance governance monitoring so all
of these topics are really key
to big corporations to make everything
uh
work really safe and reliably even at
scale
and then you what you also need is a
deployment team
so uh usually this is not the deployment
on such a cloud provider is not
a job of a data scientist but of a
devops engineer
and uh maybe a data engineer there are
like different names for
these kind of roles currently and um
yeah so we worked actually together with
a partner here
and uh i just wrote all the cleaning and
prediction predictive code
and they set up all the cloud
infrastructure and services there
next slide please
so what did what have i done as a data
scientist in this particular project
so yeah this is an nlp meet up also so
um probably some of you are
happy to see that i used normal bag of
words
tf idf vectorization together with an
ensemble of decision trees
called a random forest classifier this
is a
pretty much a baseline model a really
basic
a long time before a
bird was around this was state of the
art
and it still leads to really really good
results
um and it is set up pretty quickly
that's also why i always recommend to
first train a baseline model
and then go from there with more complex
neural net kind of stuff
with this we reached an accuracy in this
particular classification task
of over 60 percent
this is uh this accuracy is actually
higher
like 79 or something but we already
apply the confidence threshold which
is something i also really recommend
doing so that you
only take the predictions of the model
that have a
certain accuracy for example over 60 or
something
uh this is of course use case specific
with this
of course you reduce your total
automation rate so you can see here we
have introduced this 40
um not classified but
you reduce heavily the amount of
incorrect classifications
in this case to only 9 on the right you
can also see the
related confusion matrix so there are
other classes again
and uh specific uh accuracies and
uh yeah how many of the different uh
males are categorized in
in incorrect and what sort of incorrect
class
and you can also then check for example
if
uh if something important is uh is
classified into spam often
or something like this because this
would be like a really
bad case scenario um can you click
yeah thank you so uh then um
like half a year ago or something we had
some more time in the project
and then we actually implemented
something more state of the art
which is bird we just had
fortunately a really long time talk
about this so i don't really have to
explain a lot
um we used tokenizer from birch
so here we also try to make use of the
just um explain transfer learning so
we used a pre-trained bird model
that is trained on large corporate
wikipedia corpora multilingual
because also our data set optimals is
multilingual
um as you can see uh here on the right
uh now our total accuracy increased of
around
10 and so actually the transfer learning
seems to work quite well
a really fun and cool side effect was
that
actually you can see at spam the
accuracy
decreased in comparison to random forest
from
about 90 to 80 percent uh so
um bert seems to be more cautious about
what he predicts and to
spam even though he doesn't have any
clue about what spam is
but he seems to understand that spam is
something
which is really diversified and so
it was a positive side effect for us uh
of course
you can now interpret it if this is like
really
a behavior that that is led
from some sort of intelligence in
comparison to a random forest model
or if this is just a random
experience um like one
last uh note here of course those models
are much more complex to uh
implement uh it's uh but as um
our speaker before i told you already
there is a really cool library called
from having hurrying phase called
transformers that
is the one we also used i highly
recommend this library really really
good
um and yeah with this and the training
set was about
four million emails it took two to six
days depending on how many epochs so how
many
total runs you go through the data set
um
to train the model and this is also also
something you have to consider so if you
have a tough deadline
and then your model trains really long
you can only pray that the results also
will look really good
next slide so
here you can see um the actual
deployment infrastructure on aws
uh for the those of you who have never
heard of aws this will be a little bit
uh complex but we but we will uh i will
um
yeah just um uh yeah we will get to
more information informative stuff for
you guys as well
in a minute so on the left you can see
the customers
uh sending a mailtop lloyd um this
is then going to the on-prem exchange
microsoft exchange
server and then they send it to
the aws environment over an api gateway
which invokes alumna and then the lambda
stores the result in a database
the metadata and the email as pdf format
in
s3 bucket and puts an element into the
first queue
then we have a fargate instance here
called cleaning
which runs dockerized containers with a
cleaning code
so this is just picking up the elements
from the queue loading the mail
the pdf mail and extracting it
transforming it into text
and also performing some cleaning steps
like
removing stop words for example stuff
like this
um this is really cool because this can
parallelize
quite well uh so if the queue has too
many elements
more container instances can spin up and
uh
and yeah just reduce the load there um
click again yeah um so the cleaning then
is writing
the clean mail into an s3 bucket again
and putting an element into the queue
then we have another
fargate instance which is doing then the
futurization
and the prediction writing the results
into the next queue
and this is box alumna i click again
yeah and this lambda will then also
write the result into a database and
send us back
to the thread information system of
hovercroid
next slide
[Music]
so here on the top you can again see the
architecture
on the bottom left you see the
actual dashboard on aw lws cloudwatch
so all of these services that you can
see on the top
um as you can see this is a really
microservice focused architecture
so our services report their own metrics
to aws cloud watch so you have your own
log groups there
for each service um which is really uh
comfortable especially
in software because you always will have
some bugs or something will go wrong and
then you
can really quickly find where you
have to look and fix uh fix it really
fast
so on the bottom left as you can see uh
some metrics that these services report
so here we performed an actual load test
so on the top left you can see
uh the mails coming into the api service
which is around 200
per minute sorry and um you can see
below that
um the initial clue include so the
cleaning queue
um an orange is stacking up um this is
because
uh yeah exactly because the um there are
not
enough cleaning instances running
because they have to extract a lot of
pdfs and stuff so this takes some time
so then the target instance
recognizes okay there are a certain
amount of um
elements in the queue so we have to spin
up new instances and then you can see
how the amount of elements in the queue
will go down this is the first drop
and then the instances stop again
and then new elements come in of course
so it will pile up again
and then a new instance will start again
and it will go down again so this
application is really flexibly adjusting
with the load that's coming in
which is really nice and you also only
pay of course on aws for the services
that you use so only the instances that
are running
are producing costs so you most of the
time
don't need that many instances and
sometimes you have really high load
at certain times of the day and then
new instances will just spin up on the
right you will see a total execution
time
which is around three thousand
milliseconds so three seconds per mail
uh so through the whole application it
takes three seconds
to get a prediction back uh for
for like uh yeah thousands of mates um
so on the right you can see the
technology stack that we used i will
quickly
go over it again of course aws cloud
architecture 7 services scalable
reliable flexible secure
by the way i'm not paid by aws to say
this
i i'm just it's just experience um and
we also work with other cloud providers
so we are not not biased in that regard
um google cloud does the same thing for
example right okay
so you can go with any any one of these
infrastructure as code in terraform so
the whole infrastructure that you see on
the top left
is set up actually in code so you can
actually
just create a new aws account and then
uh click
kind of build and then all these
services will be set up all the code
will be transformed
will be there and everything will uh
work that's in theory of course this
will take
some some wriggling but uh
we actually deployed to a new account
within a few days um
so this is quite quite cool
um yeah we use as i said scalable
containers so you can really good
well paralyze everything you have this
isolation of micro services which is
really good concept
state-of-the-art practice actually and
you have this
high reliability through encapsulation
and ci cd pipelines so we have our
actual
cross-account deployments so we have
multiple aws accounts
and if you introduce a change you will
do this in depth and then
you will just test against it for
example run the load test again and the
production environment will just run all
the time
and then you can just say okay
everything is fine and then
deploy to qa and test again and then to
production
uh really quickly um really easily
and yeah this is yeah i would
highly recommend if you have such a big
and complex application to
go with something like this um fully
asymptotes so yeah
this q concept is also quite nice
because it's fail safe even if something
um breaks the queues will just stack up
and you will not lose anything or any
mails
okay i think that's it from my side for
now from the solution and i would give
back to alien
thank you thank you sebastian
so let's have a look on the results that
we achieved with this approach
um yeah we can uh bluntly say that we
can automate 60 roughly um of the
incoming males and of course
you maybe might say well uh what about
the rest of 40 percent
uh one thing that you should think is uh
this process has
zero automation before so automating 60
out of forty thousand meals per day is
quite a benefit
and the second thing that is maybe not
so obvious
uh at the beginning doing this um at um
accuracy level of ninety eight point
seven percent or
error rate of 1.3 percent
is quite an achievement and this is
actually what
what it makes so challenging to um apply
ai solutions um in a real
corporate level uh environments where
you cannot
accept um error rates of i don't know so
accuracies
of uh 90 or even 95 percent yeah because
the customers will not accept that you
just didn't process their
shipping instruction um yeah so saying
this
we have reached quite a high um
automation rate
at uh really good speeds so we scale up
like nothing
zero down time when we deploy things if
something goes wrong
no problem it's very robust uh the males
just pile up in the queue
and when the problem is solved they just
are
get post-processed so the business
doesn't really have to to worry about
that
these are the really nice parts of it
and in terms of
business value if you have a look uh
on our status here end of 2019
we had a promise this is actually the
timely and correct bill of lading is a
kpi that is impacted by our solution
improvement and we managed in 80
of the time to deliver our response to
the customer within four hours
and in 91 percent of the time within
eight
hours and end of november after we have
deployed the application
and it was running since few months
you can see that we achieved already
ninety percent
uh below four hours and a bit better
below eight hours
of course not all of this is due to our
solution there are a lot of initiatives
that are
adding up to this quality promise but we
are really proud
that we could provide
improvement on that
so what about some of the success
factors some of the
things that helped to achieve that
one point is you start with a business
case
and you have to understand the business
case if you want to develop
any kind of software and this is not
differently for
ai but there is something about ai
because when
you do predictions you come with a
certain um
yeah accuracy um because you're you're
definitely
working with big data so you don't apply
just a few business rules where you can
have some
checks for uh yeah 10 possible outcomes
10
scenarios and done and
what you should not forget is that
whatever your
ai is automating yeah it is
producing a result that has to be
consumed by a follow-up process you're
not in the white
the result of your ai is not valuable on
its own
it is valuable because it is consumed by
a follow-up process so if you
miss a point of having analyzing the
follow-up process
and identify how critical and this is
what had tried to talk here about
how critical uh error-ness
so a non-correct result is
like for example identifying a shipping
instruction
email as a spam well nobody is there to
detect that
the customer will wait forever and will
just
escalate so some of the
some of the results are more critical
some of your classes are more critical
to the follow-up process than others
a shipping instruction that has been
identified as a draft approval
comes actually to an expert and the
expert will see oh that's not a draft
approval this is a shipping instruction
done so less critical than spam
and that's why when you train and design
your model and optimize your model you
will definitely
uh knowing this early you will
focus on optimizing accuracy towards
the most critical um
yeah classes you have
another topic is the
key performance indicator or the
measurement of
did did this ai actually solve the
problem
of uh my customer and how do i measure
this
and the the problem the difference
between
uh standard business rule based
solutions where you have a set of
business rules a set of
use cases that you have discussed with
your customer
and mostly it is relatively easy to
to set up some metrics and and and
measure them
um in in the field of ai you
have uh you don't have this luxury and
you don't even have
the common understanding so the business
is not used
to understand to deal with uh
results that come with a certain um
with a certain confidence threshold
and with a certain uh chance to be
correct
yeah and then it comes very late that
they
realize what this means and they and
boil it down to okay i have a lot of
uh actually um results automated
but um quite a lot some of them are are
not correct so i have to deal with that
so some of the automation that that
happens
is wrong and the final efficiency gain
so like how much of the workload of the
business have
we really uh automated
is lower than the initial
measured accuracy of automation rate
that you can derive from the accuracy
of the model if it's not totally
understandable here the key messaging
message is start very early to discuss
and and transfer understanding of
what the performance the key key
performance indicators
are for the solution you're building
compliance can be surprising because you
cannot
train a model on synthetic data
i mean that's a bit incorrect we know
there's an area that's trying to to
introduce that but in general if you
want to
uh build a model that will work on real
data
you have to train it on real data real
data
in corporate environment mostly has some
confidential and
npi related information into it so you
cannot
just you can try to download in on your
corporate laptop
but your laptop will not be able to
train a bird model at scale
so you need to have your your
experiments even your initial
experiments you need to have them
potentially in a cloud well in a cloud
there you are
very near to public so you first have to
have uh yeah an nda and a corporate
uh set up in the cloud with all the
compliance
regulation uh secured there and then you
can start
and and uh even assess a use case with
with data
and even do some experiments so if you
don't have that yet in place
in in your context yeah then um
start now
solution acceptance it's a bit related
with
the with the kpi topic
so since the ai does not follow a
predefined
set of rules yeah the um
and and your users are normally uh used
to
applications and uh that um yeah
actually apply uh a set of
10 20 business rules and 10 20 use cases
uh while an ai is um if you look behind
the
we take just the this decision tree and
the random forest approach
and and a model has generated actually
and covered uh hundreds of
of business rules hundreds of use cases
that's why we
we have to go for machine learning
because the topic is too complex
for standard um standard
application development and
that's why the the users will will have
to
to learn how to um
the value and to understand the value of
results that comes with with a
confidence level
and an accuracy so with a probability of
being right
starting if you uh if you start in a
company where
um ai solutions are not yet
like rolled out and and your business
users are not yet
accustomed to that then consider that
starting early to discuss with them how
you want actually to conduct the uat
how do we want to define what is an
acceptable solution for you
very early because you have to transport
at least for the first
few project this understanding as well
yeah the rollout is also related to that
and i maybe just reduce it to it
in a in a global international company
you apply especially in nlp you apply
your model
um to to one pilot area normally you
don't apply it immediately to the whole
world
so um you don't want to to spoil it
with everybody at once um ai
applications are pretty more risky than
standard applications
and that's why taking an account that
after you have
survived the first pilot area where you
proved yes
the application is is doing the job well
maybe
it did it very well in in usa in england
uh in english and um well let's hope
that it's
doing as good in in china right
so be prepared that you will have to
roll it out step by step
in for different teams different teams
will have to accept
your your solution will have to learn
to to accept the solution and uh
and assess it and this will take for the
first project
a bit more time and efforts and costs
and budget
that's it for our from our side thank
you very much for your attention
and yeah looking forward questions yeah
one last point uh
just uh adding it to the presentation
sort of is that
um we actually get politics are hiring
so if you
i saw some uh people like are very
interested to go into the field
so we're searching for data scientists
data engineers
um and uh just like ping me on linkedin
write me and
we can have a phone call and um yeah
exactly maybe you will be one of our
data scientists and do some exciting
projects yeah thank you uh
we welcome you your questions
i uh can i jump in for a question please
sure um
question um what what is the next
automation on your plate
just a curiosity and
another question did you consider like
having a human scene
the result of the the model even when
it's
when it's the model is not sure just to
present the user this is what the model
is thinking
click on the right choice if you
have an opinion so
um normally yes
unfortunately not not playing on the
green field
i'm answering your second question first
uh
not playing on this uh second field it's
this would require a change of um
yeah very standard uh screens that we
have
and um um
and and change of of workflow this
normally
ends up to to to have to train people so
uh we didn't went this this step
um and we also learned now we did quite
an extensive
menu review over time so the
the business teams have
got from us the elements that we have
indexed so that we have automated we
told okay this mail we uh
we indexed as uh this type
and they manually checked and and um
yeah estimated so said wrong right
um and it turned out that this 1.3
error rate right so really manually
checked on on thousands of of elements
but when we compare our predictions
with um so we had a we have a dry run
mode
where we predict and we do everything
but we just don't write it to the
database
and then we compare our prediction with
what the the user has done and the error
rate is bigger
so when they let when we let them
actually
um review our our prediction
we bias them yeah so
i mean it also says that uh maybe they
are
you you yeah there are some some
there's some some freedom there yeah
some some range of freedom but
um um so yes but i would say like
um you know what actually a very good
idea
so um i told you from the corporate
point of view okay this doesn't work now
from a corporate uh point of view that
when you
want to introduce changes to a system uh
in a in in our environment it's it's
sometimes
it seems like a small change and then it
ends up
like a more complex thing so this is a
main reason why
no no not yet but maybe a good idea
so thank you for that hint and uh
for the first question what do we have
on our table
uh we actually like sebastian said we
applied
the same pattern uh even
even in our the next the next generation
of it
on dispute capturing so
when when um invoices uh when when
customers
uh find uh some something uh
need clarification on some some invoice
they send us mail and say hey
uh why why should i pay that or please
explain and
this is something that is
is also coming in volumes and and hard
to capture
and has an impact on our cash flow if
invoices are not paid and this is has
been developed
quite right after the indexing
automation
and is is running not such high volumes
but
this is the second pilot that is now
globally rolled out
and this year we are looking forward for
some similar use case so we try to
to apply the same success to to other
business areas that also receive a lot
of mails and then they have to
distribute it
and so do this mail routing yes this is
what we basically
do here um
yeah but we have some like awk matching
like getting an address and and finding
the
the organization within our system
and since the customer send us for
example the the address
um in with type pos was uh
with variations it can happen that you
just
either you create duplicates in in your
in your
system so add a new address or also you
already have it
or if you tried for example we use that
for auto booking confirmation so
automatically
if someone books something he has to
give us information like an address
where to
pick up the container and to
automatically
confirm the booking we have to have
everything in place
and if we cannot match the address to
the to
um to the organization then manual
handling is required a human has to look
in and do the matching
so this is one one of the pocs the bus
then has
analyzed and uh so
a lot of nlp ahead of us currently but
we also have use cases for
for image recognition so damage uh
damage recognition on container to
to generate uh repair work orders
and so on so hubbard lloyd is full of
use cases and
has a lot of labeled data
so before we uh give room for the next
question let
me just add some comment from the
organization
side as you have uh noticed probably
is that time is flying because um our
official end of this meetup is coming
soon
but that does not necessarily have to
stop us so we can extend our meeting
a little bit and uh just resume asking
so
um if you have to leave due to
some time constraints thank you for
being here but
let's proceed in just uh asking
a few other questions because it was a
very interesting and nice talk thanks
by the way so who's next with the
question
okay uh since no one is asking can i ask
a question
a bit of a technical question in this
regard
where hello i am uh thanks for the
really nice talk so i i'm curious about
a one challenge that we experienced in
a an industry nlp project that we that i
used to work on
is that when you have got this kind of
varied uh
data set with multiple labeling possible
on them
as you said that you already have an
organization and labeling within
yourself
but that is also that also seems like
quite a lot of manual work so
surely you are automating that process
and
what we realized in our work i do not
know if you face this one is that things
like
nair tagging etc they did not work
particularly well
on a very on an email kind of data set
have you
faced similar issues of what what should
we
think of applying if something like that
happens
so i think what you're talking about is
uh the
really usual problem of having a lot of
data
without labels right so for example
in named entity recognition uh usually
people
are just um reading it and recognizing
the entities and
and then uh taking actions based on upon
them but
not really labeling them anywhere so in
this scenario
um you can of course use some sort of
pre-trained uh
model that that already does named
editing recognition
but these are of course really limited
in the
in the tags that they provide already
and you you usually have a different use
case
um so in this particular scenario i
always recommend going with some
sort of a mixed approach like a learning
system so you have
the humans that they usually do this
task anyway
so you just introduce a sort of um
a tracking system so that you track what
they
are actually doing and then
for based upon this tracking you train
at some point
you will have them uh the labels and
then you can train
and then you have like some sort of an
initial model and then you can
could actually deploy that model and
then make recommendations
with it and then the recommendations
will be like
more or less good and then um it will
uh yeah learn and learn over time
get better with more labels um and more
interactions from the humans
but definitely this is a tricky one yes
thank you thank you for the detailed
explanation and just a
comment so we tried in our work a little
bit of this one though we had a limited
amount of inputs in terms of entities
but at some point we realized that if
that that a simple like pattern match
our sequence match up often works with
these emails better than the limited
recognizers space we use species so it
was
it is a question that has always bugged
me like how to do this one thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah sometimes the the simple
ones like
similar regular expression is working
much better than
uh and then any fancy machine learning
algorithm right so we also have always
to keep in mind
what what is there already what was used
for years
um and not just go with the latest and
greatest
because it's not always the greatest and
it really depends on on
your data especially neural nets depend
on a lot of data to learn properly
thank you okay i see 10 messages over
okay mostly thank you
so i have another question um so you
said that one of the drawbacks from
using bird was the longer training times
so have you tried working with distilled
models
which have a lot less parameters to
train
so probably that would reduce training
time while
keeping a feasible result
yeah that's a really good point uh
actually um yeah we haven't tried that
um as i said was half a year ago and
back then this was really new with this
uh distilled bird and stuff
um and uh yeah we wanted to have
it as good as possible because we had a
little bit of time for training actually
uh but yeah that's that's definitely a
really good comment um so if you
um you need quick results then try
definitely try
the smaller brother distilled bird
any other questions left i mean it was a
very good talk and answering a lot of
questions already so
that's good so we were clear enough in
our explanations
i have one question but it's related to
the first
talk okay i don't know if she's still
you
but but probably we can say that is the
part where where the general discussion
starts which would
i mean we can still go back to to the
second talk as well but
probably it's it's a good turning point
for for opening
general discussion maybe just ask the
question because yeah
i think you you guys would know because
you you work in the domain
so um in the first talk
she mentioned this transfer learning
and then there was uh one model which
was trained with one language and then
you fine tune it with other
language what was it like there yeah i
also think i remember that one yeah
yeah so um
is it like that some
some languages are easy to transfer to
other languages because they share
common roots like languages that are
based on latin
and some languages you cannot do
transfer learning because they
have like a totally different structure
so to that i only know from some paper
where google did research
with chinese a lot and actually
this was one of the main reasons what
you just mentioned that why they
uh why they introduced a special
special model sort of for chinese really
early
uh because these languages are quite
different and then
of course the transfer learning will
suffer from that quite heavily
yes
well just to just to chime in there on
that topic because we've
uh trained some well we fine tuned on
different languages with
english as the origin and we've
actually it's a distilled model
fine-tuned on predicting sentiment
and we've noticed a sort of
cross-lingual
language being created where the model
fine-tuned on just a couple of languages
could handle portuguese fine for
instance after seeing a few roman
languages when i say fine i don't mean
perfectly
but that's certainly an interesting
topic and there are some
some effects on on getting some
cross-linguality when finding nuclear
languages
probably also depends on how many
languages the original
model was trained on right yeah exactly
okay guys that was really um
nice experience i it's my first time
that i joined this meetup
and both the talks were quite nice
and yeah i hope you continue it
so is it like monthly meetup or
what's the frequency
so it's actually two meetups uh that
are taking place right at the
time now and probably it's the time
camilla are you there could you show the
the next slides are you you're already
doing that
um so it's hamburg
nlp and pi data and of course
i think we will have a joint meetup as
well in the future but
uh speaking for hamburg nlp it's just
like uh we intend to do like
one meetup every two months and
i think the same applies for pi data but
maybe one of them can jump in there
for pi data we do it every two months
and
here on this slide you can see the next
dates as well so for hamburg and lep
23 of february and for us 24 of march
thank you then i wish and thanks
and thanks for their feedback it was
very kind we're very happy that you
enjoyed the
the meetups and the talks oh yeah
then i wish you all a very nice evening
and i will
leave so have a nice evening
me too also very nice to see that
34 persons are
still in in this meet up uh in the
precious evening time
so uh thanks for the speakers it
wouldn't be possible without you
and with your topics it's really
very interesting happy to see that there
is such a large
and growing interest in data science and
nlp
four years ago when i started this was
quite different to be honest there was
like only one
i remember only one really meet up in
this
direction and um now there are a cable
so the community is growing also in
germany which is
really necessary especially when we look
into the next years
without this technology i think we will
definitely lead
behind in all industries so
um yeah cool to see all of you guys here
[Music]
and also to you thank you very much for
making this happen i know such
stuff is also with a lot of
organization hand overhead so yeah thank
you guys for
having us and doing all of this
should we close or anyone still would
like to
ask a question
if there are more questions you can also
of course
just message us on linkedin later and
and then we can from our side we can
also close it now then
and everybody interested in nlp please
just join our slack community and you
can
start discussing there and getting
information there this
qr code you see is all you need to enter
okay so thanks everyone thanks to the
speakers everyone that joined
us thanks to a hamburg nlp it was great
and see you soon thank you thank you
very much for having us
great organization great great session
thank you have a nice evening thanks
everyone
bye guys bye